maybe we're given for continued places
way that's it it's cool that holiday is
an awesome way just what you wanna show
on the road we just because you enjoy it
yeah he's gonna be here all week
let's take it humbler shakily oh you're
a tiger oh yeah I'll exaggerate the
actual depth of this shot so same thing
before this together that's it come a
little bit more this way and lean Oh
actually I could you got to swap we've
done that before bbbb you think I need
you to do the same thing with your
laughing again but looking out that way
you keep looking at me as you're
laughing I need to keep your face still
you know when you laugh to move around
try to try to keep your eyes within that
same plane you know just move your mouth
a bit of fun oh that feels funny and you
guys you can move around a little bit
but just keep on looking that way keep
on looking that way okay give me a
second give me a second
certain although some cool shots but
just that smile freakin comes out you
look you already handsome you go to the
next level with all right let's it
around a little bit now what I'm gonna
get you to do is go a bit more deeper ok
bit more deeper Dibby Dibby keep on
going give a go now I wanna get you to
squat down just sort of squat down with
this knee up that knee down there
perfect and you won't see the fact that
you're squatting but I'm just just the
perspective really face that way
yeah it's perfect when hold it there
hold it hold it keep looking that way
hey Bobby I love you mightyou I need to
entertainment value look we just have
here man over here ah okay squat down
again drop down keeper online if they
are really sensible it's not a fault
sure
bring the flowers down darling
you look like the Statue of Liberty
therefore say where giggling we're
laughing is it all that Galba getting
married now
you
now it's not going anything else you're
loving doing
beautiful mount everyone kiss your
partner go for it now
beautiful look at each other guys really
closely nice and close and and foreheads
touching turn your faces outwards
towards me beautiful eyes down at each
other and lean towards me guys it's
perfect
don't lose that it's beautiful and it
chins up a little bit crack it up
laughing looking at my way thinking
debit we're married it's up that's
freakin 35 degrees what the hell is
going on what I want you to do now mate
you turn your body towards her that's it
back close it up again now bring your
arm up early look your left arm give me
bring it up like this and bring it down
down down down down down so gorgeous and
you're kissing her cheek as you
spontaneously giggling as this is going
to be awesome
beautiful now do me a favor - oh here we
go
you guys looking at each other you guys
looking into each other you're looking
over here you snuggling in foreheads
touching okay you're looking over there
and you're looking over there in that
position like guys in that position I
gave you I need you giggling I need you
laughing having fun on the count of
three all right now important everyone
please look at the place where I told
you did not look at me
bit of giggling bit of fun um cheer I
want to see you mate I want to see you
kill in this way yeah that's it that's
it and we and don't look at me you sit
on the edge and then just arrest your
hands just lots of like that just like
that that's it really cool cross this
leg over that one that's it and just to
be a foeman can I get you - um bring
your backside right in and then just
bring this foot up nice and cash okay
better that's it and it's a perfect
perfect little bit more this way oh wait
bit mum Diego okay Ali be more this I'm
a bit more and the pocket image keeps
that oh cool
give me a second all right were there
all right guys passive passive cool
that's it no smile that's my boy
and guys looking at me as we're laughing
a little bit that's it God does
that's it we got it
three
can of three ones you're looking up
again that's a close your eyes close
your eyes chin up a bit more close your
eyes
one two go
an apt h2o abscess that's good ten price
extreme right more that's it brother
I like to see your puppy there again and
bring your elbow back attach bring that
metal work up a bit and just cross your
arms for me hang the place down there
and then face the right now okay
just it to your face a bit lower and now
your eyes a bit lower only your eyes
that's it cover it
shut up eyes at me face a bit this way
let's go don't move hold it ketchup all
right cool eyes at me man
let's see it good that's it perfect so
you know what's going on and eyes only
met that's good hold it alrighty now I
want you to do just your hands in your
pockets for a bit more and then you can
turn your face that way and eyes at my
hand that's it good until your head away
from me
that's about all that has good purpose
for some of you guys looking at each
other really cool hey guys come a little
bit closer see if you can just move out
of that way thing there hold that with
us ago yeah that's it cool so you're
like just nice and close that gives you
said liked it and you'll happiness it'll
light up as well as that caught yeah all
right beautiful and as you're doing it I
just want you to sort of never look at
me looking down looking away but try to
keep that really cool sort of passive
look okay good leaning a bit closer
voice and keep lighting it that's it
you can no you can quit forever now okay
all right so just want you to sort of -
that's it that's about it there
that's it good now as you do it actually
I want you more on the side this time
and I want you to sort of just peering
off to the right a little at sit like
that beautiful
that's it perfect now I do the exact
same thing but I want you to bring this
agate up here off your mouth there so
like keep it inhaled a little bit and
then I want to set about like that and
then blow okay and keep your eyes where
it was okay ready
I count to three one bring it down one
two three
big smile for me nice and happy home so
needy
I want you to give mom a kiss on the
forehead and dad lean this way and then
look at elv you can be close to be
closer that's it and mom big smile for
me that's it alright guys it's really
cool really cool no smiley cool that's
done it eyes on me
just want to look at me turn your face
towards me and you want your chin to
your shoulder that's it beautiful turn
that position I just need you to smile
with your eyes the way that happens you
start smiling for real and at the end of
it there's just beautiful warmth that
stays yeah so I'll help you give me a
second yeah till this way
that's gorgeous beautiful time keep it
there keep it there
just clean that's gorgeous I'm hotter
there that's it a nice and soft now just
look let the smile go that's beautiful
you
oh my gosh that's me yes I really want
the impression that you're doing it
there so and then lean what this faint
lean lean lean there ant in your faces
we're stop the eyes down yeah beautiful
beautiful gorgeous
- yeah beautiful that move
adjusting the bow even though that
obviously you didn't do it but it's sort
of pretending that you did it too chin
down gorgeous face left that's it just
there
aren't you both hands on your your
earring like this that's it beautiful
arms off the body a little bit and then
lean towards me and eyes down beautiful
all right
eyes down gorgeous
and I just seen your nipples sweep both
hands yeah it's gorgeous
be more towards me sup there lean
forward a bit and chin down really
strong look it makes perfect yeah that's
beautiful eyes down don't look right
down to your hands
waiting for towards me that's it more
more bad perfect
how's Emma darling cover up your other
eye bit more at work your way to a
squint a little one
giggling looking into each other girls
that's it for heads touching nice and
close that's it
give a cute little kiss on the hand and
mum aren't your forehead touching with
dad really close as much as a head
allows and I want your face right close
to her face there as well that's it
beautiful as you're doing that I want
sort of little soft little laughs and
giggles obviously looking at Natalie as
he doing it there for me
yeah that's gone
a lot more like that Kim I go
just your face no more left what's it
eyes down down chin down eyes down
beautiful that's gorgeous
okay girls do anything and say anything
to make her laugh go for it
Hey look
and girls look at each other actually
keep looking back at the girls and
giggling girls a bit of fun
happy ovios are there
that's it really cool guys nice smile
here hold it there so nice man that's my
passive passive cool cool I'd see it
hold it
and now in that position I want you to
rub your body on his there die make him
happy what I'm saying but you know what
like it's really weird though when she
does that to you and you're looking at
me it's a little bit awkward
and they'd like to stretch out your
right arm a little bit yeah that's
beautiful
turn your faces into each other now
they're beautiful
gorgeous
some lean towards me guys this way
that's it turn your face right into his
that's it beautiful see the glow in sort
of if you lose it you get as you put it
you put it again but see how to see it
on their bodies you just do it right
where their faces are yeah I got all
righty
give me a magnifying glass and burn away
through your left hand so just hold this
face properly yeah that's beautiful and
just spend the rest a little bit there
for me gorgeous thank you love or too
much just bring your fingers out a
little bit beautiful now eyes at me mate
that's it looking into here and they're
dying SS right intense perfect
looking right down is where before
chin up a little bit bit more bring your
forehead I love you all the other side
of her chin there on the other side of
it you fancy just there
that's it chin up a little bit there
darling that's it you're loving him
and now lean forward elute what's in
your leading back just lean look forward
and then keep your shoulders back that's
better
till she no more close your eyes breathe
through your mouth and chin up more
that's it
close your eyes beautiful don't move
now look at me daily eyes right at me
ready close your eyes again
one two three now the can of three your
eyes just here sure more close your eyes
I want a bit higher but I want to get a
little bit of light in your eyes
shoulders back a little bit
that's better ready one two open that's
are gonna so keep your hands there and
the part of it that's it
and now tilt and chin up okay that's
gonna work
that's it
you like this honor so let's get it off
here and then again just a little bit of
stress off the bus there gorgeous and
then bend that knee a little more that's
better shut up beautiful that's it now
we're talking all right close your eyes
for a second ten-chan adds perfect
double check more gorgeous don't move
but weren't you laughing but I just a
little warmth in your eyes a bit of a
smile on your eye so I bet better that's
a beautiful gorgeous yeah that's a
little bit of Duggar guy to this way
face this way that's about a beautiful
now very gently even they just bring one
knee over the other doesn't really
matter which one together just go like
that yeah stretch out your body a little
bit so we don't get the creases on the
on the on the waist so just lean forward
a little bit and there relax it back
that's a little bit chin up a little bit
face left a little bit stop know if it
was the right that's it that way and
then tilt the top of your head forward
this way that's better don't move your
left knee other more you love it that's
it good more but more stuff
drop the hand drop drop the right hand
and then hold the length of it somewhere
like that's it lean forward darling lean
lean lean chin up
come closer to me done at sea damn it
chin up up a little bit again that's it
waiting forward giggling at each other
that's it
that's right I wasn't it wasn't the
dress that's the main thing okay okay
yeah it's beautiful well well well okay
close your eyes on anything good is
hanging there
you
good shoulders right back so bring that
one out of the way yelling so bring
that's better
lean forward chin down and eyes it eyes
up that's it look at the put towards you
right now about there a little hint and
warmth in your eyes there that's better
how much better a small lift
come question was we die that's it
that's it let me uh play in a second
alright so he shot his back love that
little smile with your eyes leaders was
really really beautiful it's Jessie oh
so you lips are together it's just the
beautiful softness in your eyes is
gorgeous however there
- I was downloading
okay now why don't you do is bend your
elbows up a little bit so that one as
well yet and then bend your right elbow
a bit want to and bring it behind your
back a bit that's it and sort of hold
your veil
so give you excuse to do that and chap a
little bit and lean your body forward
towards the that's it better done it yes
but
okay let's get the ice line okay so come
really close to the glass without really
touching
bring your face here in this little
clean gap turn your face this way now
bring that here off that's it come as
close as you can without touching it
chin down more and tilt your head that
way
come closer to it now eyes down and tilt
your head closer that's it just hold
there face left you can get your hair
off again
lean towards me and hold your hands in
front of you
well here again
gorgeous fantastic
come class just put your body a bit more
bit more stop there beautiful chin up
sorry
relax your left hand a little bit that's
it that's better beautiful chin up
gorgeous and just dip her a little bit
there mate just dip it back a little bit
that's just sit and lean towards me and
touch this as well let's go don't move
don't move
that's perfect up until it's gorgeous
right guys hold on that lose that
so first of all no smile it's a very
classic shot I love it this is keep it
cool
beautiful beautiful faces Bice that way
and eyes back at me no smile really cool
everyone that is killer they move all
right so look at the top of that tree
you're going to close your eyes to relax
them on the candid spree look at that
way again now at the end there mate just
head to the pockets yep
all right ready one two and three
so if I sit on it eyes down darling Tina
Fey's right that's it
five small love gorgeous that's it
shoulders back yelling both both
shoulders back give me a second that's
it that move parts change hold on
that'll leave buddies towards me all
right hold leave a second I'll fix you
properly in a second okay chin happy
gorgeous I'd see now I'm twisted more
this way yeah till 10 you face them all
the way that's it got nice and close
like you're better kissing
and close your eyes both of you and
clever kiss on this
I want to get this light just behind the
tree so I get that hot spot out leaned
it back this way bit top till your face
left mate stop
chin up gorgeous that's it now eyes down
--is-- really soft breathe in
you
way more forward chin up and a big mouth
thought well he's like ha ha ha there we
go fantastic beautiful
all right watch your back again lean
more forward that's gorgeous turn your
face this way chin down eyes at me
beautiful
hold this hand here and this hand here
mm-hmm
hand it and the hand here now do me a
favor 10 you buy that way
oh I to do the other way now that's
better lean forward hand Minnie's foot
forward like this gorgeous
[ __ ] man down places way bit more eyes
back at me beautiful over there my head
cally I look stupid stupid Aran hahaha
he likes that's it let's go just
slightly bent
okay go check out for me do you remember
when your kid when you didn't like
something it was like the whole world
was crashing down on you alright guy
just anybody slightly towards me that's
it gorgeous chin up a little bit for
this tree
I want to turn to each other and do what
comes naturally ready one two three go
bring your forehead on dad's cheek and
while you had laughing into him and then
dad's looking at his other daughter
they're giggling away a little bit
let's get mum and now you're looking
into dad's let's look into you and mums
looking at that there as well where
click it up
give me a little kiss giggling by loving
each other all right God just take a sip
around the edge okay now turn your knees
this way yep now sit your backside more
into the chair now very gently lay down
perfect you are a knockout that's
incredible unbelievable I'll kick it on
okay ten pinching up and eyes just so my
hand is just here hi you're just
beautiful love it look
turn your face away i beautiful
to myself oh yeah put that shoulder up
darling bring the elbow closer to you
that's it Ben the shoulder rod up bit
more that's it gorgeous and the chopper
up again now gorgeous few more cars on
the road
don't walk just just stationary one more
shot come on this way
stop that perfect that's it beautiful
and turn your face that way look a bit
on tilt and eyes down chin down
what